SPEAKER 1: E. Christian
Kopff is a Professor Emeritus
of Classics at the University
of Colorado Boulder where
he taught for 36 years.
He earned his BA at
Haverford College and his PhD
in Classics from the University
of North Carolina at Chapel
Hill.
From 2004 to 2011, he served
as the Founding Director
of the Center for
Western Civilization,
a fellow of the American
Academy in Rome,
and a recipient of
the Hero of Conscience
Award from the American
Freedom Alliance.
Dr. Kopff was named Magister
Magnus by the Consortium
for Classical Lutheran
Education, the organization's
highest honor.
He is the editor of a critical
edition of Euripedes' Bacchae
and author of The
Devil Knows Latin:
Why America Needs the
Classical Tradition.
Please join me in
welcoming Dr. Kopff.
[APPLAUSE]
E. CHRISTIAN KOPFF: Thank
you for that very nice
introduction.
Welcome, ladies and gentlemen.
It's an honor to be here.
And I'd like to thank Hillsdale
College and the Center
for Constructive
Alternatives for setting up
this seminar on such
an important topic
and for allowing
me to participate.
And for giving me
my topic, which
is History and the Liberal Arts.
In his dialogue De
re Publica, Cicero
has Scipio explain
how to begin speech.
He says, quote, "I
begin by observing
a rule which all
speakers I fancy must
adhere to if confusion
is to be avoided.
That is, if the name of the
subject under discussion
is accepted, whatever it
is, the meaning of the name
should be explained."
End quote.
Well, the title of this talk is
History and the Liberal Arts,
so we can start off by
asking, what is history?
And we're going
to, in fact, use it
in several senses in ordinary
language and in this talk.
First, it may mean what
happened in the past.
The Battle of Hastings,
the Reign of Henry VIII,
the good news of
Jesus and how it
spread from Jerusalem to Rome.
Second, history may refer
to studying and recounting
the past in many forms.
Textbooks, documentaries,
works of literature
like Herodotus's Histories
or Gibbon's Decline and Fall.
Third, as an
academic discipline,
history is one
subject among many--
social sciences,
arts, humanities,
and physical sciences--
that comprise the
undergraduate curriculum
of a liberal arts education.
There were seven liberal
arts that St. Augustine first
cataloged in the
fourth century AD.
Three formed the arts of
language, the trivium.
Grammar, dialectic or
logic, and rhetoric.
Four comprised the arts of
mathematics, the quadrivium.
Arithmetic, geometry,
astronomy, and music.
Why are these arts liberal?
In her award-winning book
Cultivating Humanity:
A Classical Defense of
Reform in Liberal Education,
Martha Nussbaum writes
of what she calls,
quote, "an education that is
liberal in that it liberates
the mind from the bondage
of habit and custom."
End quote.
Since she holds
a PhD in classics
from Harvard University,
Professor Nussbaum
knows better.
The adjective liberal comes from
the Latin word liber, free, not
a slave.
According to
Aristotle, free people
act after deliberation
and discussion,
while slaves obey
without debate.
Over the centuries
the liberal arts
have educated students for
many roles in many societies.
Ancient, medieval, and modern.
In America, and especially
in the age of the founders,
the freedom of the
liberal arts has
been first and foremost
the freedom of a citizen.
Thomas Jefferson,
for instance, wrote
to his state legislator,
Colonel Charles Yancey,
on January the 6, 1816.
Quote, "If a nation expects
to be ignorant and free
in a state of civilization,
it expects what
never was and never will be."
End quote.
Jefferson described his
bill for public education
in his only book, Notes
on the State of Virginia,
final edition 1787.
First, students should be taught
to read, write, and reckon.
In addition,
Jefferson said, quote,
"Their memories
may here be stored
with the most useful facts
from Grecian, Roman, European,
and American history."
End quote.
For Thomas Jefferson,
knowledge of history
was as fundamental and essential
as the grammar and arithmetic
of the seven liberal arts.
He explains, quote, "Of all
the views of this law--"
the one on public education--
"none is more important, none
more legitimate than that
of rendering the
people the safe as they
are the ultimate guardians
of their own liberty.
For this purpose, the
reading in the first stage
when they will receive
their whole education
is proposed as has been said
to be chiefly historical.
History, by appraising
them of the past,
will enable them to
judge of the future.
It will avail them of the
experience of other times
and other nations.
It will qualify them as
judges of the actions
and designs of men.
It will enable them
to know ambition
under every disguise
it may assume
and knowing it to
defeat its views."
End quote.
Every citizen should know
what Jefferson called
the useful facts of history.
But the better educated should
actually read great historians.
Jefferson wrote young Peter
Carr on August the 19,
1785, about studying
at William and Mary.
He wrote, quote, "I
advise you to begin
a course of ancient
history, reading everything
in the original and
not translation.
Having ascribed proper
hours to exercise,
divide what remains
into three portions.
Give the principle portion
to history, the other two,
which should be shorter,
to philosophy and poetry."
End quote.
Jefferson urged
reading historians
in the original languages.
He commented in the Notes
on the State of Virginia,
quote, "The learning
Greek and Latin
I am told is going
into disuse in Europe.
I know not what their manners
and occupations may call for,
but it would be very ill
judged in us to follow them
in this instance."
End quote.
Many American founders
and English Whigs
shared Jefferson's
belief in the importance
of studying ancient history.
One was the English
journalist Thomas Gordon,
who lived from 1651 to 1750.
Gordon is best known as the
co-author with James Trenchard
of a series of 144
political essays
espousing the weak
cause in England
and appearing under
the pseudonym of Cato,
the traditionalist
contemporary of Cicero.
They were published in book
form after Trenchard's death
as Cato's Letters, which
was a bestseller in England
and the American colonies.
Bernard Bailyn of Harvard in
his study of colonial pamphlets
called Cato's Letters,
quote, "The most frequently
cited authority on matters
of principle and theory."
End quote.
Clinton Rossiter of Cornell
in Seedtime of the Republic
wrote, quote, "No one
can spend any time
on the newspapers, literary
library inventories,
and pamphlets of
colonial America
without realizing that Cato's
Letters rather than John
Locke's Civil Government,
was the most popular,
quotable, esteemed source
for political ideas
in the colonial period."
End quote.
The memory of Cato's
Letters survives
in the name of the
major libertarian
think tank in Washington,
DC, the Cato Institute.
It's not named after
an ancient Roman.
It's named after the
pseudonymous author
of Cato's Letters.
After Trenchard's
death in 1724, Gordon
stopped writing fiercely
polemical essays
on contemporary
issues and devoted
the rest of his life to
translating two Roman
historians, Tacitus in
two volumes, 1728 and 1731
with later revisions,
and Sallust in 1744.
He devoted four years, 1720
to 1724, to Cato's Letters,
but 20 years, 1724 to
1744, to ancient history.
He prefaced his translations
with lively essays
showing their relevance to the
themes of free institutions,
citizenship, and tyranny.
The pages of Tacitus are full
of tyrannical emperors and brave
senators who stand up to
them and are defeated.
The American founders
saw their world
through the lens of Tacitus
as adjusted by Thomas Gordon.
For John Adams, "The
morality of Tacitus
is the morality of patriotism."
You should know that Whigs
called themselves patriots.
In retirement, Jefferson wrote,
"I read one or two newspapers
a week, but with reluctance
give up even that much time
from Tacitus and Horace."
For John Quincy
Adams in 1819 when
he was Secretary
of State, quote,
"To live without a Cicero
and a Tacitus at hand
seems to me as if it were a
privation of one of my limbs."
End quote.
Modern historians find
it impossible to believe
that English Whigs and American
founders took the past so
seriously.
Stanford's Jack Rakove
writes of the framers
of the US Constitution in his
Pulitzer Prize-winning book
Original Meanings:
Politics and Ideas
in the Making of
the Constitution.
Rakove writes, quote,
"The convention
delegates of 1787 to '88
came to their task fresh
not from research
in their libraries,
but from the business
of managing a revolution
and conducting public affairs
at every level of government.
Conscious as they were of
the fate of other republics
and confederacies,
ancient and modern,
the lessons of the
past they weighed
most heavily were drawn
from their own experience."
End quote.
Is Rakove right?
In mid-August 1787, John Wilson
of Pennsylvania and James
Madison of Virginia tried to
amend the convention's vote
on July the 16 about the
two houses of Congress
by moving that bills
of appropriation
be allowed to originate
in either house, not just
the House of Representatives.
Their forceful
speeches were based
on reason and practical
political observation,
what Rakove calls
"their own experience."
They argued, one, there
was no logical reason
to restrict such bills from
proceeding from either house,
since both houses had to
approve the bills in any event.
In addition, two, the lower
houses of state legislators
had often behaved irresponsibly
over the decades since 1776.
Their motion was
soundly defeated
and historians
rarely mention it.
The debate is
important, however,
because of the
response it provoked
from distinguished elder
statesman John Dickinson, who
in opposing the
amendment expressed
clearly and explicitly
the principles that guided
many framers.
We have Dickinson's comments,
by the way, because Madison
kept extensive
notes on the debates
in the convention, which
were published decades later.
Dickinson spoke,
quote, "Experience
must be our only guide.
Reason may lead us astray.
It was not reason
that discovered
the singular and admirable
mechanism of the English
Constitution.
It was not reason that
discovered or even could
have discovered the
odd, and in the eyes
of those who were governed
by reason, the absurd mode
of trial by jury.
Accidents probably
produced these discoveries
and experience has
given sanction to them.
This is then our guide.
And has not experience
verified the utility
of restraining money bills to
the immediate representatives
of the people?
Whence the effect may have
proceeded he could not say,
but the effect was visible
and could not be doubted.
Shall we oppose
this long experience
to the short experience of 11
years, which we had ourselves
on this subject?"
End quote.
Dickinson's rhetorical question
refutes Jack Rakove's dictum
which was, as you
remember, "the lessons
of the past that the
framers weighed most heavily
was drawn from their
own experience."
In fact, almost the
opposite's true.
What weighed most heavily with
the delegates in Philadelphia
during the summer
of 1787 was not
what Dickinson called "the short
experience of 11 years, which
we had ourselves," which
is what we today mean when
we use the word experience.
No.
What mattered most to them was
English history and common law,
which was based on precedent.
For John Dickinson and the
delegates who voted with him,
experience meant primarily
history and tradition.
As historian Douglas
Adair noted, quote,
"Experience shows our history
proves our expressions that
are used interchangeably
throughout the convention
by members from all sections
of the United States."
End quote.
ME Bradford entitled his
book on the founders A Better
Guide Than Reason.
But that's not quite right.
Dickinson did not say
that history and tradition
were better than rationalism.
He said "Experience
must be our only guide."
The history of the Philadelphia
convention and American history
in general needs to be
rewritten to show Americans time
and again privileging,
biblical, classical, German,
and English history
and tradition
over Enlightenment rationalism.
Recent American history
needs to be analyzed
in light of the catastrophic
consequences of privileging
an abstract rationalism
over history and tradition.
The founders thought
the study of history
essential for education.
History as an
academic discipline
has seen the steepest decline
in measures of all disciplines
since the 2008
recession, according
to the American Historical
Association's journal
Perspectives on History.
Why has the percentage
of undergraduates
who major in history shrunk
so much in recent decades?
Often, students
prefer STEM majors
to humanities and
social and history
because they expect STEM to
leave them to good paying jobs.
These expectations
may be exaggerated.
A professor in one prestigious
biology department told
a group of colleagues,
"Our majors
think they're all going to
med school, but only about 20%
of them get accepted."
According to a report
from the US Census
Bureau published on July
the 10, 2014, quote, "74%--
74% of those who have a
bachelor's degree in Science,
Technology,
Engineering, and Math,
commonly referred
to as STEM, are not
employed in STEM occupations."
End quote.
74%.
STEM grads often find that
although their first job does
pay more than those of
liberal arts students,
they eventually hit
a glass ceiling.
During the Republican
primary debates in 2016,
Senator Rubio of Florida
opined that America
needed, quote, "More welders
and less philosophers."
End quote.
He meant fewer philosophers, but
let's not get distracted here.
[LAUGHTER]
Don't get me
started on that one.
On the stage debating
him was a Stanford
graduate with a history
major and a philosophy minor,
two subjects often
pointed out as ones
that don't lead to
high-paying first jobs.
Her first job indeed
was as a secretary,
confirming the prejudice.
Her last job was CEO
of Hewlett-Packard.
OK.
Carly Fiorina's is an
extreme case, I grant you,
but not unique either.
University of Colorado
President Bruce Benson
wrote the faculty
in August the 4,
2016, that his
administration had, quote,
"surveyed the degrees earned by
the CEOs of Colorado's top 25
companies.
We found that most had
an undergraduate degree
in the liberal arts and
only then an advanced degree
in specialized areas
such as law or business."
End quote.
There is a deeper
reason, though,
for the marginalization
of history
and the arts of language
in favor of STEM
and the arts of mathematics.
For most of Western history,
the seven liberal arts
have proclaimed the equal value
of language and mathematics,
trivium and quadrivium.
But usually, the
arts of language
have been more influential
and widely studied.
The growing prestige
of Plato's vision
of science as best
done by mathematics
has privileged disciplines
that use mathematical models.
In my experience at the
University of Colorado's Honors
program, honors theses
based on mathematical models
are viewed as more impressive
than those arguing from history
and political philosophy.
Aristotle reminded his students
that mathematical models
favored by his
teacher, Plato, need
to be confirmed by observation.
Sometimes history of mathematics
suggest different results.
So let me give an example.
Mathematical models suggest
that global free trade
is superior to the products of
national economies protected
by the tariff because goods
are cheaper for consumers.
Economic history,
however, suggests
a different conclusion.
At the time of the American
founding, the United
States where what we today would
call a third world economy,
one largely agricultural
and producing raw materials
for British factories.
The federal government was
funded by tariffs and excise
taxes, which taxed foreign
countries and businesses.
Many Americans wanted
the tariff used only
to meet the government's
budgetary needs,
but others like Alexander
Hamilton and later Henry Clay
wanted a protective tariff
to favor American industry
over foreign competition.
When the Republican Party
achieved a majority in Congress
after the secession of the
southern states in 1861,
they passed the
protectionist moral tariff.
President James Buchanan
signed it into law his last day
in office.
Abraham Lincoln later
signed two stronger versions
of the tariff.
As Alfred E. Eckes showed in
his book, Opening America's
Markets, in the century
after the founding,
the United States developed
from a producer of raw materials
to an industrial
powerhouse under a regime
of national autarky
funded by the tariff.
The 16th Amendment gave
free trader Woodrow Wilson
a chance to sabotage the
tariff, but this was reversed
by Harding and Coolidge.
Free traders attribute the
prosperity of the roaring
'20s to lower income tax rates.
But Coolidge himself in his
essay on William McKinley
attributes it to the tariff.
In this essay, Coolidge
praises McKinley because he,
quote, "Took up the work
of Hamilton and Clay,
reestablished their principles,
and under his leadership,
the government re-adopted
their policies."
End quote.
Their principles, as
the essay makes plain,
were protectionism.
And their policies,
the protective tariff.
FDR worked to
undermine the tariff,
but the demolition of
America's industrial base
and the hollowing out
of our middle class
really took off with the
Kennedy round of GATT
in the late 1960s followed
by NAFTA in the 1990s.
Of course, the
roaring '20s ended
with the Great Depression.
Marxists blamed it on the
inherent contradictions
of capitalism while free traders
blamed the Smoot-Hawley tariff,
which did not go into effect
until the Depression had
already begun.
Milton Friedman and
Anna J. Schwartz
in A Monetary History of the
United States published in 1963
showed that the
Great Depression was
brought on by the monetary
policies of the Federal
Reserve.
It was for this work
of economic history,
not his advocacy of
global free trade,
that Milton Friedman was awarded
the Nobel Prize for Economics
in 1976.
If we're to make rational
decisions about our nation's
future, economic
and otherwise, we
need to supplement the
lessons of mathematics
with those of history.
Classical educators immerse
their students in the past
by studying dead
languages and history.
Progressive educators
think the future will
belong to those who innovate,
and so our education
must be innovative.
Support for the
classical model comes
from the research of
psychologist K. Anders
Ericsson of Florida State.
Ericsson studies the most
successful practitioners
of a wide range of different
skills and professions
from policing to chess,
whom he calls experts.
Ericsson is the
expert on experts.
Let's examine his
research on chess.
Chess is a challenging
intellectual activity.
The communis opinio
is that grandmasters
win by thinking ahead more
moves than their opponents.
Ericsson's research, however,
shows a significant correlation
not with innovation,
but with hours
spent studying the games
of earlier grandmasters.
Joshua Foer discusses
this in his book,
Moonwalking with Einstein.
Let me quote Foer.
Quote, "Using
magnetoencephalography,
a technique that measures the
weak magnetic fields given off
by a thinking brain,
researchers have
found that higher
rated chess players are
more likely to engage the
frontal and parietal cortices
of the brain when they
look at the board, which
suggests they are
recalling information
from long-term memory.
Lower ranked players are
more likely to engage
the medial temporal
lobes, which suggests they
are encoding new information."
End quote.
Let me summarize this research.
Amateur chess players innovate.
Grandmasters remember.
Outstanding achievement
involves knowing the past.
By immersing students in
dead languages and history,
the liberal arts aim at creating
grandmasters of citizenship.
Jefferson's view
of the importance
of classical literature and
ancient history from the 1780s
did not change after decades
spent as ambassador to France,
member of Washington's cabinet,
and two terms as president
of the United States.
In Jack Rakove's words,
quote, "Managing a revolution
and conducting public affairs
at every level of government."
End quote.
Jefferson wrote to Nathaniel
Macon from Monticello
on January the 12, 1819, quote,
"I read no newspapers now
but Ritchie's, and in that
chiefly the advertisements,
for they contain the
only truths to be
relied upon in a newspaper."
I regret to say that Thomas
Jefferson sometimes criticized
our great free press.
Jefferson-- we're all
shocked by that, so please--
[LAUGHTER]
--I understand.
Jefferson went on to say, "I
feel a much greater interest
in knowing what has passed 2,000
or 3,000 years ago than what
is now passing.
I read nothing,
therefore, of the heroes
of Troy, of the wars of
Lacedaemon and Athens,
of Pompey and Caesar,
and of Augustus too."
End quote.
Clinton Rossiter in his
Seedtime of the Republic
described the
founders' education.
Quote, "It's easy to smile
at the dull, rigid, crabbed
methods that prevailed
in colonial colleges.
But if we judge the vineyards
by the fruit they brought forth,
we must acknowledge
them of fertile ground,
of learning, science,
reason, and liberty.
They may not have taught young
men enough useful knowledge,
but they did teach them in
their own tradition-ridden way
to think, communicate, and lead.
To think, communicate,
and lead."
And Rossiter goes on, "The roll
call of Harvard and William
and Mary men in the revolution
should be evidence enough
that Latin, logic, and
metaphysics, to which we
may add ancient history,
were a rich fertilizer
in the cultivation of
reason, virtue, honor,
and love of liberty."
Progressive educators focus
on liberating students
from the bondage of tradition
and the dead hand of the past.
They reject studying the dead
languages that have given us
the vocabulary for philosophy,
theology, medicine, science,
law, and citizenship
and the history
of the Athenian democracy,
the Roman Republic,
and the American founding.
George Orwell warned against
this attitude in his novel
Nineteen Eighty-Four
when he described
the visit of Winston Smith
and his girlfriend Julia
to the apartment of
the government agent
O'Brien, who treats
them to good liquor
and access to books
and conversation
not available to most people.
Sounds like an early
seminar of the Center
for Constructive Alternatives.
Eventually, there's
enough alcohol
left for one more toast.
I hope we won't reach
that condition tonight.
And O'Brien fills their glasses.
"'What shall it be this time?'
O'Brien said, still with
the same faint suggestion
of irony."
Seems to always have
this smirk on his face.
"'To the confusion
of a thought police?
To the death of big brother?
To humanity?
Nah.
To the future?'" "'To the
past,' said Winston Smith.
'Yes,' O'Brien agreed
gravely, no more smirking.
'Yes,' O'Brien agreed gravely.
'The past is more important.'"
George Orwell was a Democratic
socialist, not a conservative.
But he was a
cultured man, and he
knew that the beauty
and freedom we enjoy
are legacies from the past.
History and a liberal
arts education
teaches students to value
our traditions of language,
history, and law,
and employ them
to live as free citizens
of a nation founded
with consensual institutions,
committed to debate
and discussion, using
the lessons of history
and the liberal arts of language
to persuade our fellow citizens
and devote ourselves
as our ancestors did
to the cultivation of
reason, virtue, honor,
and love of liberty.
Another reason to study history
in the liberal arts curriculum
is that these stories, whether
recounted orally or preserved
in great works of literature,
touch our hearts in ways
that grammar and logic do not.
The old Sunday school
hymn used to proclaim
"I love to tell this story
will be be my theme and glory
to tell the old, old story
of Jesus and his love."
The hymn makes a point
that's valid for many stories
in secular as well
as biblical history.
"I love to tell the story
because I know it's true.
It satisfies my longings
as nothing else can do."
The minister in Robert
Frost's "The Black Cottage"
had an insight we need to hear.
"Most of the change we
think we see in life
is due to truths being
in and out of favor.
As I said here and
oftentimes, I wish
I could be monarch
of a desert land.
I would devote and
dedicate forever
to the truths we keep
coming back and back to."
I like that poem, but I
do have a quibble with it.
Lands that are dedicated to
the truths and stories "we
keep coming back and
back to" are not deserts.
They're full of family farms,
local factories, and churches.
Their families have
a lot of children.
Their citizens are soldiers.
Their story is our story.
Today we like to
proclaim, nothing's
the same after some
important event.
If we have to hear
about the past,
we want it laid out
for us in PowerPoint
or downloaded onto our Kindle so
we can skim it on the airplane.
Give us the gist, and
if you don't mind,
spare us the history lesson.
Traditional liberal
arts education, however,
insisted on the history
lesson, beginning
with the ancient
Greeks and Romans.
What most Americans
value about America--
consensual institutions, the
rule of law, private property,
science, faith--
cannot survive without the
ancient traditions that
inspired and maintained them.
We are free and
creative not because we
inhabit a new nation
dedicated to a proposition,
as somebody once said, but
because we are citizens
of what General MacArthur
called the United
States in his last great
speech at West Point.
Quote, "This beloved land of
culture and ancient descent."
"Culture and ancient descent."
End quote.
John Adams wrote his
friend, Dr. Benjamin Rush,
"I should as soon think
of closing all my window
shutters to enable me to see
as of banishing the classics
to improve Republican ideas."
The liberally educated value
of the past and the great
works that preserve that past.
"We all want progress," CS
Lewis told his radio audience
in 1942.
"But progress means
getting nearer
to the place you want to be.
If you're on the
wrong road, progress
means doing an about turn and
walking back to the right road.
And in that case, the man
who turns back soonest
is the most progressive."
End quote.
It's not a question of
choosing the right major.
We're on the wrong road.
We've privileged job training
over the liberal arts,
global free trade over family
farms and local businesses,
technology over great
books, the consensus
of self-proclaimed experts over
the wisdom of our ancestors.
It's time to turn around and
go back to the right road.
We shall recognize it when we
get there, because, you see,
it's the road home.
Thank you for your
kind attention.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 2: Thank you, Dr. Kopff.
We now have time for Q&A,
so if you have a question,
please make your way to
one of the microphones.
I have to remind students
that good questions will
be considered for extra credit.
[LAUGHTER]
E. CHRISTIAN KOPFF:
That's bribery.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Thank you very
much for [INAUDIBLE]..
How do you suggest the
[INAUDIBLE] understanding
how it applies to
us, how we use it?
How do we incorporate
that in today?
How do we inspire those who
are not inspired [INAUDIBLE] we
understood [INAUDIBLE]?
E. CHRISTIAN KOPFF: Yes,
that's a good question,
and I don't have a
good answer for it.
One way you-- and my impression
of it, inspiring students--
and there actually is
research supporting
it is that love what you teach.
Be enthusiastic about
your country and its story
and the stories
that lie behind it.
I had a friend in
our education school
whose research showed that the
most effective part of teaching
more than knowledge
and more than skill
was thinking your
subject was important.
And he said, this is bizarre.
So the one thing we can't teach
is the most important thing,
is thinking it matters.
Once that happens, especially
when you rely on the fact
that these people, the people
that our founders found
important were the people that
the people the Reformation era
found important, the people
that Dante and Petrarch
found important.
Ezra Pound says somewhere,
writings and people
that have been found to be
interesting and important
for thousands of years are
probably not very boring.
And we sort of need to have
confidence that this is true.
There's a sense that--
especially when
you teach classics,
you really notice this.
When is the day going to come
when people are going to say,
this is ridiculous?
This was thousands of years ago.
How can this possibly
matter to us now?
And the answer is you sort of
need to believe that it does.
And John Dickinson's
point is the one
that really is relevant here.
This is what has made sense for
people for a long, long time.
And it's not just John
Dickinson in the 18th century.
Frankly, the argument
that Dickinson uses--
the argument about
accidents probably
produced this and
experience showed,
history showed that it worked--
is the same argument used by the
great biologist Konrad Lorenz
in his book on mankind's mortal
sins where he as a biologist
compares the traditions, what
one of mankind's mortal sins is
[NON-ENGLISH],,
destroying tradition.
And he says, tradition
of our ethical
and our religious traditions
and our political traditions
too, I would add, he views
like the human genome, which
he didn't think was
created or designed.
He thought it happened because
accidents caused mutations
and good mutations survived.
But it comes to the same thing.
And he says the
great traditions,
the ethical and religious
traditions of mankind
have the same validity
that our genome does,
and nobody could invent
it, either one group
or the other group.
What you need to
do is be confident
that that's true when
you're looking at it.
Don't look at it
as something that--
and this is the problem
I have with Martha
Nussbaum, of course.
She assumes that
the past is wrong
and that tradition
is irrational instead
of assuming that something
that's made sense for so long
is going to continue to make
sense if we just give people
a chance to hear it.
Does that respond to it?
Yes?
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much for
your wisdom and exhortation.
I'm wondering, for
those of us who
strive and desire to
be scholars of history,
when we see history
beginning to repeat itself
and when history itself is the
best testimonial to those who
are deaf to its very
prophecy, is there any room,
or how much room is
there for compromise when
it comes to our culture's desire
for STEM answers, I suppose?
When people don't want
to listen to history,
but history holds the answers,
how much room is there
for us to compromise
when it comes
to warning them of
the very thing that
is likely to repeat itself?
E. CHRISTIAN KOPFF:
Well, here, I mean,
you bring up a
really good point.
And the fact is we have an
unfair advantage, because they
have to write the--
you've all seen Karl
Rove writing these things
on the whiteboard in
numbers and on and on.
But the fact is people
respond to stories
and heroes and villains much
more than they do to numbers.
Now sometimes that's wrong,
and sometimes the numbers
tell us things we
need to listen to.
But for the most
part, we get to bring
in the heroes and the
villains and the stories that
really make sense to more
people and to ourselves also.
The really wonderful book on
the founders and the classics
has a wonderful title, which is
The Founders and the Classics.
And it's by a great-- wonderful
scholar named Carl Richard.
And it's spelled Richard,
but he's a Cajun,
and he, like the French,
leave off the last letter.
And his book includes a chapter
on the heroes and the villains.
Who are the heroes
and the villains?
And some of these, of
course, are people that
change places at other times.
Julius Caesar was a villain
back in the 18th century.
100 years later, the great
liberal classicist Theodor
Mommsen, Caesar was a hero.
And for Dante,
Brutus and Cassius
are in the lowest part of Hell.
They're right next
to Judas because they
were disloyal to their emperor.
So the heroes and villains
may change sometimes
for different reasons.
But for the most
part, these are things
we can make to come alive for
people because they were alive.
So I think we have
the unfair advantage,
if we'll take advantage
of it and we'll insist,
wait a second.
I'm going to
believe those models
when it comes out that way.
But they don't all
come out that way.
Does that make sense?
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank
you for your time.
I was curious about
tradition, because it
seems like when we refer
to tradition, [INAUDIBLE]
there's a golden age that
we sort of look back to.
Is that fair to say?
Or is there a sort of
standard that we look back to?
Because it seems as if almost
every generation [INAUDIBLE]
tradition.
I guess, where are we
supposed to look back
to as sort of the standard?
Like, will we look back to just
as far as the American founding
or back to the middle
ages or farther?
E. CHRISTIAN KOPFF: Right.
Great question.
And the success or the argument
for the great traditions
is precisely that they've
been through so many ages.
And one of the points that
Konrad Lorenz makes even more
clearly than John Dickinson
is that no one person or study
group or generation
could come up
with the human genome or
the great moral traditions.
Anyone who's read CS Lewis's
book we've got quoted here,
he lists all the commonalities
of ethical tradition
all over the world in
The Abolition of Man.
And the argument is precisely
that no one generation
has it all.
Tennyson says in his
Arthurian poem somewhere,
"The old order change is
making way for the new,
and God fulfills
himself in many ways,
lest one good custom
should destroy the world."
There not only is not a pure
golden age, but they're--
the whole point of these
traditions-- ethical,
political, et cetera,
or religious--
is precisely they've been
through so many different ages.
Now I mean, I don't want
to present an argument
from Christianity that doesn't
involve the Holy Ghost,
obviously, but here's
something that's
been through
antiquity, the Middle
Ages, and the modern world.
It's known a lot more than
anybody now could know.
Now, let me just
modify what I just
said by bringing up the point we
had about heroes and villains.
Every healthy society,
every healthy person
has somebody who views
as a kind of hero,
and every healthy society
has some age that they
view is as a wonderful age.
But when you honor it
and you honor those,
you honor them for
the good things
and you know there
are bad things too.
Whereas the great
traditions that
have made their way through
so many ages, so many peoples,
and so many times,
that's the thing
that I would argue for
in favor of tradition.
And why I would argue
again for history,
because history allows us to
look when these things worked.
And are there times
when they didn't work?
Does that make sense?
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for
speaking to us today.
So I had a question.
You were referring a lot to how
the founders took into context
these greats from the past.
And all of them paid attention
to many of the same people.
But even among the
founders, these people who
are reading the same works
from the same people,
they had different--
not even
interpretations, but you
could say different applications
of the same lessons.
Can you speak to how, even
though lessons from history
are unchanging, our
interpretations of them
are changing, how do we know
how to apply history correctly
and not in a twisted
manner, maybe twisted
by our own personal experiences
or the age in which we live?
E. CHRISTIAN KOPFF:
So I'm going to let
Aristotle answer this question.
And one of his points-- and
he makes this in the ethics
and he makes it On The Soul--
is that there are people that
are experts in a little
area, and they're
really good in that area.
But they can't connect it to
the wider society they live in.
And for Aristotle
and for Plato, there
are these architectonic visions.
And for example, for
Aristotle, economics
is subordinate to politics.
I know many people who think
it shouldn't be that way.
Economists should be telling
the politicians what to do.
But the idea that there's a--
the point is that a
liberally educated person,
a person educated
to be a citizen
has that kind of
education, how to use
the opinions of smart people.
So I will say a couple of
things that I said today
the leading scholars in
the field don't agree with.
OK?
In fact, there's a
genuine consensus
that the founders are--
the founding was an
Enlightenment project,
and that it was a
distinctly modern project.
And I just don't
mean the other side.
I mean people on our side,
really good people on our side.
So I mean, it's legitimate.
I happen to think
the evidence when
evaluated carefully
and critically
would show that somebody's
right and somebody isn't right.
But still, there's legitimate
points there to be made.
And by the way, people
who thought that Americans
threw away their old prejudices
and created a new society,
there's de Crevecoeur's
1782 work Letters
From an American Farmer
where he says exactly that.
He sounds exactly
like Bernard Bailyn
and Jack Rakove and Martha
Nussbaum back in 1782.
Now, I think there were a lot
more people like John Dickinson
and Thomas Jefferson.
But still, part of a
liberal arts education
is that you with a good
can decide what
the experts who are
number one in their
teeny area but can't
see the whole picture,
how this fits into things.
So I mean, if I'm right--
if I'm wrong, of course,
then we should hand over
our lives to Dr. Fauci or
whoever the expert is, right?
You laugh.
There are parts of
Boulder that wouldn't
be laughing at that comment.
But the fact-- it's the job
of the liberally educated,
the people who have
a vision of history,
of language, of philosophy,
of literature too
who should be judging what
the experts in little areas
are telling us.
So that ultimately, there is
a way to get a right answer,
but the openness to
debate is not a bad thing.
That's one of the things
we should be learning
from the study of the past.
Does that make sense?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
Thank you.
E. CHRISTIAN KOPFF: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
so much for your talk.
This is [INAUDIBLE] what
you were just talking about,
but what are your thoughts
on the idea of allowing
or requiring students to
major in a certain subject
[INAUDIBLE] college.
[INAUDIBLE] say that
that's not [INAUDIBLE]..
And then also, are
there certain majors
that don't really fit with
a liberal arts education?
E. CHRISTIAN KOPFF: So it's
a really good question.
I don't have a really
good answer for it.
The idea of majors is something
of a concession to a developing
situation.
The advantage of
departments is they
allow a certain kind of academic
standard to be maintained,
and the disadvantage
is they tend
to leave out things
that don't fit
into their narrow
academic specialty.
Are there things
that shouldn't be
part of an undergraduate
liberal arts education?
Well, all we have to do
is go to the same issue
of the American History
Association's Perspectives
on History and look at the ones
that are doing well since 2008.
They're the ones that
shouldn't be there.
Or go on to Forbes, and Forbes
will say, the majors that
give you the best first job.
Right?
And list these things.
And it's computer science
and it's all kinds
of engineering things.
And I'm saying that a little
bit carefully, because actually,
classics is in the
top 20 in the list.
With a classics major,
you actually, as a rule--
according to Forbes, I
don't know this myself--
but according to Forbes--
who would question Forbes?
Not I, certainly.
Think that classic majors--
now, they're top 20.
They're not top 10.
The top 10 are all
computer science stuff.
And I also get this
because I'm always having
trouble with my computer.
And I go into the
library where they are,
and there's the kids fixing it.
They're all undergraduates.
And I remember one telling me.
After he told me
this, I asked others
and it turned out to be true.
When I came here, I was
going to be a bio major.
Then I found out only about 20%
of them even get to med school.
So I had, by the way, provoked
the statement that I just
mentioned from the
colleague, confirming
what the student had heard.
So I switched to
computer science,
because that way I'm guaranteed
to get a good first job.
And he's right.
Guaranteed is too
much, of course.
But it is-- it's better
than one in five.
It's better tan eeny,
meeny, miny, moe,
which is sort of what
you get the other way.
So I mean, those
are the subjects
we shouldn't be teaching.
My school-- I went to
a small liberal arts
school, Haverford College.
500 men.
Smaller than you guys.
By the way, it's
bloated since then.
They let in women.
It's now 1,100, so it's bloated.
But they just sent us propaganda
to make us give more money.
And one of the arguments
was 10 years ago,
there was one computer science
major, and now there are 40.
Isn't this good?
And I thought, well,
you know, it certainly
makes it easier on
my checkbook when
you're telling me things
which I'm completely
opposed to on principle.
[LAUGHTER]
These people, they should
be studying mathematics.
They should be studying science.
They shouldn't be studying
at a liberal arts school.
They should be learning
to be the Carly
Fiorinas of these
businesses in 10 and 15
years, which is what you guys
are going to be, by the way.
You can tell your parents
that anyhow if you want to.
I once was teaching
a course for one
of our courses done in a dorm.
We were trying to--
thought it was a great idea to
teach people in their dorms.
And it was a Greek
history course,
and two kids came up to me
after about a month and said,
ancient history is so great.
I was going to be
a physics major,
but I'm thinking of
becoming a history major.
And I said, one, you should
follow what you find important.
Two, your parents are going
to hire a hitman from Miami
to kill me.
[LAUGHTER]
Because they're going to
think you've committed career
suicide by leaving a science--
a STEM subject and
going into this.
So please warn me if you
see large sums of money
on your parent's credit cards
going to flights from Miami
to Denver, because I'll know
to start protecting myself.
You know, basically,
the more you
go back to the older
liberal arts education,
this is the education
that gave us
Dante, that gave us Luther and
Calvin, that gave us Aquinas
and William of Ockham, frankly.
They gave us the founders.
And this is the education
that prepares you to think,
communicate, and lead.
And that's where things
like computer science
are distracting.
Thank you.
I hope that answers.
SPEAKER 2: We have time
for one last question.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for
speaking to us today.
My question is, have
you seen a movement back
towards the liberal arts
or to history in general
in any of your colleagues
or in academia?
Or do you feel like
you're sort of alone,
standing in this
fight for history?
E. CHRISTIAN KOPFF:
Well, fortunately--
I mean, if you do
your job properly--
and understand that teaching
is part of your job--
and you're excited
about your subject,
there are going to be majors.
And the languages, all
of them, the living ones
except for Spanish as
well as the dead ones
have had their problems.
Shortly after that report
from the Census Bureau
came out talking about 74%
of STEM undergraduate degrees
didn't end up doing STEM,
one of the leftist journals
went and investigated it.
And now I can't remember
which one it was.
And what they discovered
was that at Yale,
history was very popular.
And I think it was the
third most popular major.
And at Princeton, they were
having so many students
they were hiring.
That's what we
really care about.
Who's getting the
faculty positions, right?
On and on.
And their theory was, you see
who goes to Yale and Princeton
but the rich people
who are going
to oppress the rest of us.
And they were cleverly
learning about the past
and learning about
these traditions
and having the poor proles
study these subjects that
led directly to a good first
job whom they would then rule,
of course, because
they'd be the CEOs
where these other guys
would be the other.
So there is a rumor that
in really good places which
have really good
departments too, by the way,
good students understand that
these are important subjects.
And I know that to name
a non-Ivy prestige school
but still a prestige
school, UT Austin,
created some wonderful
humanities departments just
by paying people at the Ivies
more than they got paid there
and luring them off and
creating wonderful French
and classics and German
and history departments.
You know, because it was--
because they were majors.
I will say our administrators
don't think that.
I was at a meeting where the
provost came in and said,
of course I love the liberal
arts and I would support it.
And I was silly
enough to say, well,
you know, that's great, because
you could create the greatest
classics or French or history
department in the world
with half of what
it costs you to hire
junior faculty in our
biology departments,
in our physics departments, in
our chemistry departments where
you need labs and all this
tremendous infrastructure.
And of course, the
look on his face, he--
tell when someone
isn't sincere, right?
Well, yeah, well, we
could hire those people.
But then when no students
took their courses, what would
we do?
We'd be stuck with them.
So I said, OK.
Thank you, sir.
Thank you.
I didn't understand.
Thank you for clarifying that.
So there is some evidence
that smart people know
enough to study
the great subjects,
but in terms of the sheer
numerical aspect, what was true
a few years ago is still true.
The humanities are in trouble
as far as enrollments go.
SPEAKER 2: Thank you, Dr. Kopff.
E. CHRISTIAN KOPFF: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you, ladies and gentlemen.